ابدا معك سجل قصف على منازل في دير البرح
عما اسفر واطلعنا على ايضا القصف عموما في
المنطقه الوسطى
للقطاع نعم جلال حقيقه المحافظه الوسطى
وتيره القصف متصاعده خلال الساعات الماضيه
حيث الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه اغارت
على عده منازل للمواطنين في دير البلح وفي
مخيم النصيرات بالاضافه ايضا في منطقه
مخيم البريج وسط قطع غزه هذه الغارات خلفت
ما يقارب من 15 شهيدا وصلوا هنا مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى بالاضافه الى عدد كبير من
المصابين الذين وصلوا جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه العنيفه والتي استهدفت
الجمعيه جمعيه النخيل غرب مدينه دير بلح
بالاضافه في شارع النخيل هناك كان منزلا
لعائله البحيصي اما بخصوص القصف في مخيم
النصيرات فهو استهدف مربعا سكنيا كاملا
هذا الامر ادى الى وقوع اعداد من الشهداء
والمصابين وصلوا هنا مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
وهناك ايضا في مستشفى العوده في مخيم
النصيرات المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لا تكاد
تتوقف في مناطق الشرقيه للمحافظه الوسطى
عن اطلاق قذائفها باتجاه المناطق الحدوديه
وبالتحديد في منطقه جحر الديك تحدث معنا
شهود عيان عن اطلاق عدد من قذائف المدفعيه
باتجاه منازل المواطنين في تلك المنطقه
وبالاضافه الى مخيم البريج شرق مخيم
البريج وشرق مخيم المغازي شهدت خلال
الساعات الماضيه اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه
وصفت بانها الاقوى خلال الساعات الماضيه
بين المقا الفلسطينيه والقوات الاسرائيليه
التي مازالت تتمركز بالقرب من الحدود
الشرقيه لمخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج وسط
قطاع غزه